we hang out from time to time against
your will i went
i went to a a dodger game with you out
here and we were sitting there was the
greatest experience we were sitting
there watching the game and then they
start to play seven nation army
and it's so cool to sit next to the guy
who wrote it while they're all singing
it i started to improvise lyrics about
how you're making money right now
but it's like sitting next to the guy
who invented
is that weird for you to hear your music
in in
arenas like that people come up to me
all the time and they think i they think
that it makes me mad for some reason i
don't know why they think it upsets me
but i think it's the most as a
songwriter that's the greatest thing
that could ever happen is yeah it
becomes folk music because people take
it over and i don't know of that many
songs where they're not saying words
they're chanting a melody yes so as a
songwriter that's pretty unbelievable
that that connected with people in that
way it's just a guttural feeling for
them i don't know in europe it's a huge
thing at soccer stadiums they they they
play that line and they chant it
now i have to pay you uh but
you know what's good this we found this
clip this is hamburg germany celebrated
the 825th anniversary of the port of
hamburg and this is how they celebrated
it check out this clip
[Music]
[Applause]
that's that's gonna be the best thing
ever yeah i didn't know that uh boats
could play songs yeah sure it does it
does la cucaracha
all right now i gotta ask you this uh
last night you played a show i'm coming
to see you tonight but uh you played a
show last night uh at the fonda here in
l.a this was what you put up on the
marquee
who is performing
you look at that and you wonder okay of
those three acts who's the opener
oh the beatles the beatles are opening
that one the beatles open and then
einstein like does some comedy oh no
jesus jesus next in that oh jesus next
and then einstein got it
that's a big argument who wants to
follow einstein
i guess that's true yeah
jesus is no way no way
i'm not going on after him
you could turn water into wine it's
getting old
uh a reviewer said uh you so many nice
things have been written about your
music this one really grabbed me though
that you uh you play rock and roll from
the crotch
how do you what it sounds like that
sounds like it like a playground insult
or something yeah
no they meant it in a very nice way i
mean i think they meant that the power
of rock and roll was coming out of your
crotch
there's really no question here
i just wanted to make you
just wanted to make you feel really
weird i have nothing to say to that yeah
okay it's funny